Tras ocho años ocupando el despacho
oval, la etapa de Barack Obama como
Presidente de los Estados Unidos llega a
su fin. Atrás queda uno de los
presidentes más carismáticos y
populares, un presidente que llegó con
promesas de cambio y renovación. Incluso
prometió cambiar la relación de
Estados Unidos con el resto del mundo.
De hecho, desde la época de Jimmy Carter
ningún presidente estadounidense
se había esforzado tanto en distanciarse
de su predecesor en lo referido a
política internacional.
Obama apostó por el multilateralismo,
por reconocer el papel de China y por
terminar con el concepto de Estados
Unidos como sheriff del mundo.
En este vídeo vamos a repasar los
principales puntos de la política exterior
de Obama.
Así que, empecemos: Irán y el acuerdo
nuclear.
El acuerdo nuclear con Irán alcanzado en
julio de 2015 tras dos años de intensas
negociaciones es sin lugar a dudas una
de las decisiones más controvertidas y
polémicas que ha tomado la
administración Obama en política
exterior.
Tras heredar unas relaciones más que
tensas, prácticamente situación de
preguerra, ante la posibilidad real de
que Irán desarrollarse la bomba
atómica.
A lo largo de sus dos legislaturas
Obama ha utilizado la política del palo
y la zanahoria para presionar a la
teocracia iraní.
Prueba de ello es que mientras
continuaban las negociaciones, el consejo
de seguridad de la ONU aprobó en junio
de 2010 la resolución 1929 que
castigaba a Irán con duras sanciones
económicas por negarse a demostrar el
carácter no militar de su programa
nuclear.
La resolución prohíbe a Irán fabricar
misiles balísticos que pueden llevar
armas atómicas e invertir dinero en la
extracción de uranio. Podemos decir de
forma sintética que el acuerdo firmado
con Irán pone límites a su programa
nuclear a cambio del levantamiento
progresivo de sanciones. Asi, Teherán se
ha comprometido a no desarrollar ni
adquirir armas nucleares, a no producir
uranio enriquecido durante los próximos
15 años y a deshacerse del 98% de su
materia nuclear. El acuerdo levantó una
gran oleada de críticas al presidente
Obama, tanto por parte del partido
republicano como por Israel y muchos
de los países árabes. Sí, ésta es una de
las raras veces donde la confluencia de
intereses entre Israel y los países
árabes -como Arabia Saudita- les hace
dejar atrás su histórica
confrontación.
Los críticos al acuerdo afirman que
Teherán mantendrá su capacidad para
desarrollar la bomba y que además el
levantamiento sanciones inducirá un
crecimiento económico en el país que
le otorgará al régimen iraní ingentes
recursos con los que incrementar su
influencia en la región.
De hecho el propio presidente de Israel,
Benjamin Netanyahu, intervino en el
Congreso de los Estados Unidos para mostrar
su oposición al acuerdo y calificarlo
como "error histórico".
Habiendo pasado su niñez y adolescencia
entre Hawai e Indonesia
la identidad cultural de Obama está
mucho más liga al Pacífico que al
Atlántico. algo que probablemente haya influido de forma relevante en su
concepción del mundo y sus
planteamientos políticos. Porque sin
género de dudas, si algo ha
caracterizado a Obama ha sido su
determinación por trasladar el eje de
atención de la política y los
intereses estadounidenses hacia el
Pacífico. Y no se trata precisamente de
un objetivo sencillo,
China se ha convertido en toda una
potencia que aspira tener una influencia
determinante en la región y en el mundo.
Y todo sea dicho, Obama ha sido
comprensivo con ello y ha buscado
reconocer el papel chino en los foros
internacionales.
Ahora bien las diferencias son enormes y
Pekín ha demostrado una creciente
beligerancia: Corea del Norte, Taiwán
y las disputas territoriales con Japón son
espacios donde de la política china
choca frontalmente con los intereses de
Estados Unidos.
Ante esa situación, Obama respondió con
una decidida voluntad de consolidar el
papel de Estados Unidos como nación y
potencia del Pacífico.
Así bajo la Administración Obama,
Estados Unidos ha decidido incrementar su
presencia militar en la región
incluyeron despegue de nuevas bases
militares y la presencia de más tropas
permanentes, por ejemplo en Australia;
concentrar en el Océano Pacífico el 60% de todos los recursos de la
Marina estadounidense e impulsar la
integración comercial.
Precisamente en esta línea se firmó
recientemente el que tal vez sea uno
de los mayores éxitos de Obama,
el TPP, o Acuerdo Transpacífico de
Cooperación Económica, el mayor tratado
de libre comercio jamás firmado y que
representa ni más ni menos la friolera del 40%
del comercio mundial.
Aunque Obama se planteó como
objetivo recomponer la relación con
Rusia, muy deteriorada tras la agresión
rusa a Georgia y la decisión de
Washington de desplegar un escudo
antimisiles en Europa oriental,
lo cierto es que la cosa empezó con
buen pie y en 2009 la propia Hillary
Clinton -Secretaria de Estado por aquel
entonces- anunció en Moscú el deseo
de los Estados Unidos de reiniciar sus
relaciones con Rusia y superar pasados
malentendidos.
A partir de ese momento se sucedieron
importantes acuerdos, como el Start III, que
contemplaba una importante reducción de
los arsenales nucleares de ambos países;
la colaboración en el teatro afgano o el
apoyo de Estados Unidos al ingreso de
Rusia en la Organización Mundial del
Comercio.
"El séptimo exportador del
planeta con 140 millones de habitantes, entró oficialmente este miércoles
en la OMC tras 18 largos años de
negociaciones. Sin embargo con el inicio
del segundo mandato de Putin,
todo empezó a torcerse y tras el
Maidán en Ucrania, la ocupación de
Crimea y las consiguientes sanciones a
destacados líderes del Gobierno de Putin
las relaciones entre ambos países
saltaron por los aires y alcanzan hoy su
momento más tenso donde el regreso de
una escenario de Guerra Fría no es en
absoluto descabellado.
Precisamente y, probablemente, como consecuencia
del conflicto con Rusia la atención de
Obama a los asuntos europeos ha ido de
menos a más.
De hecho durante estos años hemos visto
cómo Obama decidía no acudir a la
cumbre entre Estados Unidos y la Unión
Europea de 2010 que por tanto tuvo que
cancelarse.
Reproches a los
países europeos por su falta de
compromiso a la hora de cumplir con el gasto
militar requerido por la OTAN y
criticar duramente la caótica gestión
del escenario de postguerra en Libia, un
conflicto en el que Estados Unidos
asumió un papel secundario y que
podemos decir ha sido dada la desastrosa
situación de Libia hoy, uno de los
grandes errores de la Casa Blanca en
política exterior.
A pesar de ello uno de los grandes
objetivos que se planteó Obama en su
segunda legislatura y que de momento
tardará en ver cumplido es el TTIP,
el tratado de libre comercio entre
Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea, del que
hablraremos más adelante.
"El asunto no es si va a haber o no comercio,
la cuestión es en qué términos".
Obama ha tenido que consumir muchas más energías de la que tenía
previstas en Oriente Medio,
prácticamente ha cumplido con sus
compromisos de retirar las tropas en
Irak y Afganistán contra consejo del
Pentágono,
por cierto. Y en materia antiterrorista ha
hecho un intenso uso de los ataques
selectivos mediante el uso de cuerpos
especiales y sobre todo de drones. De
hecho podemos decir también que Obama es
el Nobel de la paz quien más misiles
ha lanzado en la historia.
Cosas de la política.
"El premio Nobel
de la paz resulta ser el premio Nobel de
los drones".
Durante el mandato de Obama se han
realizado más de quinientas operaciones en
las que se calcula se han eliminado a más
de tres mil terroristas.
Eso sí los daños colaterales entre la
población civil también han existido. El
balance logrado arroja luces y sombras:
por un lado Al Qaeda ha sufrido un gran
retroceso y Obama incluso consiguió
hacerse con la valiosa pieza que era Bin
Laden, uno de sus grandes éxitos sin duda.
Pero por otro lado muchos culpan a su
estrategía del crecimiento del Estado
Islámico en la zona y el fracaso de las
llamadas "primaveras árabes".
"El Estado Islámico está homenajeando
al Presidente Obama. Es el fundador del
ISIS.
Él fundó el ISIS."
Respecto a Siria,
digamos que ha sido un conflicto en el
que no ha querido enredarse y en cuanto
a Israel, con quien ha mantenido unas tensas relaciones, se despide con un
acuerdo de asistencia militar
récord en sus importes. En fin por el
camino se quedan un montón de
iniciativas históricas como la visita a
la Habana, el impulso a la lucha contra
el cambio climático donde Obama ha
conseguido grandes éxitos en su agenda,
como por ejemplo la asunción de responsabilidad
por parte de China.
Sin duda Obama ha sido un presidente cuya política exterior
a un presidente cuya política exterior
ha sido controvertida y en general no
ha gustado ni a la izquierda ni a la derecha.
¿Será ésta una prueba de su mesura?
Sólo el tiempo lo dirá. Personalmente
no soy el mayor fan de Barack, ni mucho menos
pero hay que reconocer que la
Administración Obama ha expandido el
comercio, ha sabido orientar a los
Estados Unidos a la zona del mundo que
más está creciendo, que más se está
desarrollando y ha dejado atrás la
filosofía de la guerra como solución a
todo conflicto. Bueno, ¿vosotros qué pensáis? ¿Marcará un antes y un después
la gestión de Barack Obama en los
Estados Unidos? Y de ser así, ¿será para
bien o para mal?
Espero vuestros comentarios, si os ha resultado interesante el vídeo dadle a like y suscribiros al
canal si aún no lo habéis hecho ya. Y por supuesto
nos olvide de seguirnos en Facebook y Twitter.
¡Hasta la próxima!